so my name is Marisol I'm a pianist
composer and I've been challenged to go
through levels of music complexity at
the piano what's amazing about music
composition is that explores so much and
the possibilities are really endless in
terms of what you can do with all
different pitches what's incredible is
that composition can go to so many
different places and the possibilities
are really endless a quick disclaimer
this is based on my interpretation of
the word complexity in this context it
can mean different things for different
people and this all I'll be using happy
birthday it's common it's familiar and
if it's your birthday you're in luck at
some point in history someone decided to
arrange these notes in this particular
order so let's first play it with just
one finger in the simplest way possible
and this is our melody with that I'm
going to add just another finger I'm
alternating notes and I'm creating the
simplest form of a bass line by adding a
third finger I'm supporting the bass
line now we have a stronger sense of
harmony these two fingers are called a
drone and played together and you can
hear it in rock shuffle
by adding a third finger in the left
hand that's a court we can move these
chords around take it somewhere else
but we eventually come back home so now
I can take this chord I can break the
notes up and now I have an arpeggio
[Music]
another way to break up the chords might
be or
I'm taking the notes of the court and
I'm opening up like a fan this movement
is now giving us a deeper sense of
rhythm so what happens when we take our
arpeggio break it up by skipping the
second note these groups of three makes
the piece more like a waltz you may be
familiar with the waltz or waltz phase
in groups of three one two three one two
three we're beginning to find form I
could choose different genres which are
in different groups or rumba or stride
[Music]
but we're gonna continue with waltz for
now so let's go back to the right hand
melody the goal is to add more
complexity and presence to the melody by
expanding it I could make it more
complex simply by using more than one
finger at a time
[Music]
but for this level I'm gonna keep it to
one finger at a time and add
embellishments by simply adding notes
around the melody I am decorating it
almost like adding lacing to something
and this makes it sound prettier there's
more motion to it there's more color to
the melody there are more elaborate ways
to do it and in certain cases you can
hear the melody less or more now a
warning on decoration complexity isn't
just about a bunch of added notes and
craziness one way to interpret the
purpose of this video might be something
like this but for me physicality doesn't
equal complexity we can make things much
more complex in other ways so up until
now we've been dealing with the melody
and the harmony so two parts singer and
a band what happens if we have two
singers two voices now if we swap these
parts the main melody is on the bottom
it's much more complex add to that a
third melody on the bottom so that the
main melody is sandwiched in between the
other two parts
[Music]
it's like having three singers singing
together so now we're dealing with
polyphony multiple voices and the
complexity is in the interaction between
all of them and what's harder is to hear
the happy birthday melody but put away
voices for a second how else can we make
the melody less recognizable we can
change the rhythm so far it's been in
groups of three one two three one two
three
what about groups of four one two three
four one two three four and now we're
gonna make it more complex by making it
five one two three four five one two
three four five one two three four five
one two three four five one so so far
we've been dealing with adding stuff to
the melody and rearranging it in
different ways but now in changing the
DNA of happy birthday it's becoming more
of a composition so before we move on to
level 13 let's see what it sounds like
with all of the levels combined
[Music]
so there are different tools that we can
use to change the color the mood and the
personality of what we're dealing with
say for example we add extensions you
can enrich in the harmony
[Music]
so that we changed the harmonic
progression
or the scale
[Music]
or the arrangement of the scale
these are all tools that we can use to
create new material we can also combine
certain techniques as well that's happy
birthday in E major let's take those
cords and apply the melody in C major so
those levels were about manipulating
harmony but what does it mean to
manipulate the melody there are more
tools that composers can use to
transform the melody in unrecognizable
ways these are more abstract let's say
we play the melody backwards or flip
upside down
[Music]
upside-down and backwards
or fragments displace it in different
registers these are all techniques that
composers used to abstract the melody
and find new material out of it kind of
like what Picasso does with his
paintings where he abstracts parts of
the human body and displaces them around
the canvas so we have one last final
level the complexity of this last level
is really hard to articulate because it
has to do with creative alchemy and
combining all the different parts so
that they come together in a way that
reflects me as an artist and what I want
to express in music you can just prepare
a dish but it's different from really
cooking it with heart and with the soul
so when you put all of the different
levels together this is what I would do
[Music]
complexity isn't something that can be
straightforwardly measured in music yet
it's been an interesting exercise to
notice the different nuances that are
involved in creating something that's
complex it was super challenging because
I didn't really know what complexity
means in the context of music because it
can be applied to different things in
this case I chose to apply it to certain
aspects of music composition and it was
about the architecture of things
tomorrow I may look at this challenge if
I were to revisit it and focus on an
entirely different aspect of music
whether it's sonority or textures
something completely different there are
a lot of creative choices along the way
that affect how the final product will
turn out to be whatever you do with
music it always has to have some sort of
purpose other than just being an
intellectual exercise because otherwise
you know what's the point so that's it
thanks choir
[Applause]